Esto no es más que juegos políticos lo
que estamos viendo Es políticos
republicanos que están tratando de
distraer sobre el tema del aborto esta
semana hemos visto que el senador
Lindsay y republicanos han introducido
un una provisión de aborto a nivel
nacional y esto ha quedado una polémica
increíble en el senado de los Estados
Unidos Entonces los republicanos están
tratando de distraer sobre ese tema que
los que las encuestas
aprobado de que no es un tema popular
para ellos se han perdido un montón de
lecciones especiales
electorales entonces están tratando de
cambiar el tema al tema de inmigración
donde ellos se sienten más cómodos
y también ron de santis el gobernador de
la Florida que aprobó
esta esta operación para mandar a estos
migrantes a Marte svengers él no está
corriendo para la gubernatura de la
Florida él está corriendo para la
presidencia en el 2024 Entonces él no le
importa la elección que va a pasar en el
2022 es lo que le importa es pararse en
una en un debate
presidencial en el 2024 en con otros
candidatos republicanos que se van a
postular para la presidencia y poder
decir yo fui el más trompista yo fui el
el candidato más antimigrante y ganar la
candidatura para poderse postular a la
presidencia esto nomás no es más que
juegos políticos con las vidas de estas
personas inmigrantes que están escapando
de dictaduras de situaciones muy
difíciles en sus países
señor Kennedy precisamente Qué está
pasando con esos migrantes cuando llegan
a Estados como Nueva York como
Washington considerados como estados
santuario Cómo es la situación que se
les brinda y realmente tienen ellos la
opción de regularizar su situación
Bueno lo que podemos ver Es que en
Massachusetts en martes la comunidad
realmente
brindado apoyo a estas personas así es
muy inspirador ver de la forma en que
han sido bienvenidas pero lo que les
pasó a estas personas es que cuando
les mintieron les dijeron que iban a ir
a Boston no a Marte svengers dijeron que
iban a llegar a la Ciudad de Boston le
dijeron que cuando iban a llegar ahí
iban a tener trabajos y ayuda a alegar
para regularizar su situación y cuando
llegaron a esta isla de marte swinger
los dejaron básicamente sin apoyo sin
ningún tipo de guianza los tiraron como
animales porque esto es un juego
político no que están jugando estos
republicanos con las vidas de estas
personas y Y si estas personas van a
poder regularizar regularizar su estatus
Eso depende
en lo creíble que es su caso de asilo
que es otra cosa que hay que notar sobre
estas personas estas personas no son
personas indocumentadas que están
tratando de no pasar por el proceso o
esconderse y pasar desapercibidas estas
son personas que tienen casos de asilos
que están tratando de seguir el proceso
legal para poder quedarse en este país y
y han sido Víctimas de estos juegos
políticos que están jugando
zonas como ron de santis realmente es
horrible Ver que esto está pasando en
este país y es realmente Cruel
No no tengo palabras para para
esta gente pasando